[applaudissements]
[musique]
Étape 2
Cette question financière financière était plus tôt
n'en parle pas
Seul
Quatre
dieu
[musique]
vaudou j'ai l'impression que tu es trop léger, grand frère
juste
Si je ne le voyais pas, mes connaissances manquaient.
juste un peu
J'ai l'impression qu'il était trop tard pour commencer à bouger.
[musique]
dieu
bg
bien
[musique]
N'est-ce pas
West Tokyo mettra fin à l'augmentation du terrain demain 19 mars, comme prévu.
apprivoiser
jour
[musique]
Ouais
b je
n vaudou
Ce ballon est un dispositif de propagation de l'infection qui comprend également de l'art de créateur, n'est-ce pas ?
doit finir tôt
[musique]
Quatre
bronzer
Ouais
le 4
ee
bien bien bien bien bien bien bien bien
tee tee
Ouais
déclaré le 7 janvier
En intramusculaire, la zone où des mesures de proximité doivent être mises en place est la première ligne depuis la préfecture
Nous ferons ce qui suit : Il n'y a pas de changement dans la période de mise en œuvre jusqu'au 6 mai.
[musique]